et oui à la verrière on aime la galette
des rois
pas d'originalité ni de fantaisie la
préférée de toutes celles à la
frangipane
au départ la galette c'était la galette
à la crème d'amande crème d'amande c'est
une frangipane mais sans crème au beurre
sur un crème pâtissière pardon ce qui
fait qu'elle est légèrement plus
bourrative plus pur en amendes
automatiquement mais plus bourrative et
les gens délaissent un peu ça il pas
faire l'apologie palais et puis bon bah
on fait plaisir à la clientèle ont fait
en france j pal s'excuse maximum entre
800 et 900 galette se vendent autour de
l'épiphanie dans la boulangerie de
jean-pierre et malgré la concurrence du
supermarché la clientèle ne désemplit
pas sylvain lauzon ne dirait pas le
contraire en 25 ans de carrière dont 14
dans cette boulangerie de la verrière
le pâtissier a appris tous les secrets
de la galette
voilà la fête cette année ses volte
personnages de walt disney là le disque
du dessus
voilà enfin on soude
le petite route qui est important pour
enlever l'air qui est emprisonné quand
on a remis le chapeau cheetah je peux
faire un petit décor qui va se revoir
à la sortie du four la galette devrait
reposer cinq heures avant d'être
enfourner sur une heure de travail si 20
ans préparera une centaine et pour
chaque qu'elle est acheté une bouteille
de cidre offerte
de quoi régaler les plus gourmands